you're considered for position as FDA
commissioner in the Trump Administration
and I think one of in terms of the
network state in terms of the digital
world one of the seminal acts in the
history of that was the Banning of trump
from Twitter he make the case for it and
against it sure so first let me let me
talk about the FDA thing sure so I was
considered for a senior role at FDA but
I do believe that and this is a whole
topic we can talk about the FDA
um I do believe that just as it was
easier to create Bitcoin than to form
the FED right reforming the FED
basically still hasn't happened right so
just as it was easier to create Bitcoin
than to reform the FED it will literally
be easier to start a new country than to
reform the FDA it may take 10 or 20
years I mean think about Bitcoin it's
only about 13 years old right it may
take 10 or 20 years to start a new
network state with a different
biomedical policy but that is how we get
out from this perhaps the single worst
thing in the world which is
harmonization regulatory harmonization
can describe regulatory harmonization
regulatory harmonization is the
mechanism by which
U.S regulators
impose their regulations on the entire
world so basically you have a monopoly
by U.S Regulators uh this is not just
the FDA it is SEC and FAA and so on and
so forth and for the same reason that a
small
company will use Facebook login that
will Outsource their login to Facebook
a small country will Outsource their
regulation to the USA okay with all the
attendant issues because
I mean you know the names of some
politicians can you name a single
regulator at the FDA no no right yet
they will brag on their website that
they regulate I forget the exact numbers
I think it's like 25 cents out of every
dollar something along those lines okay
it's like double digits okay
that's a pretty big deal
and the thing about this is you know
people will talk about quote our
democracy and so on but many of the
positions in quote our democracy are
actually not subject to democratic
accountability uh you have tenured
professors and you have tax-exempt
colleges you have the salzburgers that
New York Times who have dual class stock
you have
um you know a bunch of positions that
are out of the reach of the electorate
and that includes Regulators who have
career tenure after just a few years of
not necessarily even continuous service
so not accountable to the electorate
they're not named by the Press
and they also uh aren't accountable to
the market because you've got
essentially uniform Global regulations
now the thing about this is it's not
just a government thing it's a
regulatory capture thing big Pharma
companies like this as well why because
they can just get their approval in the
US and then they can export to the rest
of the world right I understand where
that comes from as a corporate executive
it's such a pain to get you know access
in one place so there's a team up though
between the giant company and the giant
government to box out all the small
startups in all the small countries and
lots of small Innovation right there are
cracks in this now right the FDA did not
accrue itself well during the pandemic
for example it denied I mean there's so
many issues but one of the things that
even actually New York Times reported
the reason that people thought there
were no covid cases in the U.S early in
the pandemic was because the FDA was
denying people the ability to run covet
tests and the emergency use
authorization was you know emergency
should mean like right now right but it
was not it was just taking forever and
so some Labs did Civil Disobedience and
they just disobeyed the FDA and just
went and tested uh academic Labs with
threat of federal penalties because
that's what they are they're like
they're like the police okay and uh and
so we're sort of retroactively granted
immunity because nyt went and ran a
positive story on them so nyt's
Authority is usually greater than that
of FDA if they come into a conflict MIT
run stories then FDA kind of gets
spanked right
um and it's not you know probably
neither party would normally think of
themselves that way but if you look at
it when nyt goes and runs stories on a
company it names all the executives and
they get all hit when it runs stories on
a regulator it just treats the regulator
usually as if it was just some abstract
entity it's Zuckerberg's Facebook but
you can't name you know the people who
the career bureaucrats at FDA
interesting right it's very interesting
it's a very important Point like that
person who's like named in their face is
is known like you just as an example you
know Zuckerberg's face and name most
people don't know Arthur G Salzburg they
couldn't recognize him right he's a guy
who's inherited the New York Times
company from his father's father's
father that is unaccountable power it's
not that they get great coverage that
they get no coverage you don't even
think about them right and uh so it's
invisibility right there's some aspect
why fauci was very interesting because
in my recent memory
there's not been many faces of
scientific policy of science policy yeah
and he became the face of that and you
know as as uh there's some of it is meme
which is uh you know basically saying
that he is science or to some people
represent science but in in the quote
unquote science or whatever yeah the
positive aspect of that is that there is
accountability when there's a face like
that right but you can also see the
factory example shows you why a lot of
these folks do not want to be public
because they enter a political you know
and media Minefield I'm actually
sympathetic to that aspect of it what
I'm not sympathetic to is the concept
that in 2022 that the unelected
unfireable anonymous American regulator
should be able to impose regulatory
policy for the entire world we are not
the world of 1945. you know it is not
something where these other countries
are even consciously consenting to that
world just as Give an example you know
there's a concept called challenge
trials okay the the moderna vaccine
was available very very early in the
pandemic you can just synthesize it from
the sequence and challenge trials would
have meant that people
who are healthy volunteers okay they
could have been soldiers for example of
varying agents who are there to take a
risk their lives for their country
potentially okay it could have been just
healthy volunteers not necessarily
soldiers just Patriots or whatever kind
in any country not just the us but those
healthy volunteers could have gone and
at the early stages of the pandemic we
didn't know exactly how lethal it was
going to be because you know Lee Wen
Liang and you know 30 year old
30-somethings in China were dying from
this it seemed like it could be far
worse how lethal the the the virus would
be yeah it may be by the way that those
who are the most susceptible to the
virus died faster earlier it's as if you
could imagine a model where those who
were exposed and had the lowest
susceptibility also had the highest
severity and died in greater numbers
early on if you look at the graph like
deaths from covid were exponential going
into about April 2020 and then leveled
off to about 7 500 10 000 a day and then
kind of fell right but it could have
gone to 75 000 at the beginning so we
didn't know how serious it was so this
would have been a real risk that these
people would have been taking but here's
what they would have gotten for that
basically in a challenge trial somebody
would have been given the vaccine
and then exposed to the virus
and then put under observation and then
that would have given you all the data
because ultimately the synthesis of the
thing I mean yes you do need to scale up
synthesis and Manufacturing and what
have you but the information
of whether it worked or not and was safe
and effective and like that could mean
gathered expeditiously with volunteers
for challenge you think there would be a
large number of volunteers absolutely
what's the concern there was is there an
ethical concern of taking on uh
volunteers well so let me put it like
this had we done that
we could have had vaccines early enough
to save the lives of like a million
Americans especially seniors and so on
okay soldiers and were generally First
Responders and others
um you know I do believe there's folks
who would have stepped up
um you know to to take that risk the
heroes Walk Among Us yeah that's right
like if military service is something
which is ritualized thing
um people are paid for it but they're
not paid that much they're really paid
an honor you know and in in Duty and and
pictures that is actually the kind of
thing where
um I do believe some some fraction those
folks would have raised their hand for
this important you know task I don't
know how many of them but I do think
that we the volunteers would have been
there there's probably some empirical
test to that which is a there's a
challenge trials website there's a
Harvard profit put out this proposal
early in the pandemic and he could tell
you how many volunteers he got
um but but something like that could
have just shortened the the time from
pandemic to functional vaccine right to
today's even if you'd actually really
acted on it the fact that that didn't
happen and that the Chinese solution of
lockdown that actually you know at the
beginning people thought the state could
you know potentially stop the virus stop
people in place it turned out to be more
contagious in that basically no NPI no
non-pharmaceutical intervention really
turned out to work that much right
and actually at the very beginning the
pandemic I said something like look it's
actually February 3rd about a month
before people you know I was just
watching what's going on in China I saw
that they were uh doing digital
quarantine like using WeChat codes to
like block people off and so on I didn't
know what was going to happen but I said
look if the coronavirus goes pandemic
and it seems it may the extreme Edge
case becomes The New Normal it's every
debate we've had on surveillance
de-platforming and centralization
accelerated pandemic means emergency
powers for the state even more than
terrorism or crime and sometimes a
solution creates the next problem my
rough forecast for the future the
coronavirus results in quarantines
nationalism centralization and this may
actually work to stop the spread but
once under control States will not see
their powers so we decentralize and I
didn't know whether it was going to stop
the spread but I knew that they were
going to try to do it right and you know
look it's it's hard to call every single
thing right and I'm sure you know
someone will find some errors but in
general I think that was that was
actually pretty good for like early
February of 2020 right so it's my point
though the point is rather than copying
Chinese lockdown what we should have had
were different
regimes around the world to some extent
Sweden defected you know from this right
they had like no lockdowns or what have
you but really the the the access that
people were talking about was lockdown
versus no lockdown
um the real action should have been
challenge trials versus no challenge
trials we could have had that in days
okay and that those are two examples on
both vaccines and testing there's so
many more that I can point to so those
are kind of decentralized Innovations
and that's what fdh stand for FDA can
stand for it or something like FDA right
ah so let's talk about that right
something like FDA so this is very
important in general the way I try to
think about things is
V1 V2 V3 as we've talked about a few
times so FDA V
well right so what was before FDA right
so there was both good and bad before
after you because people don't
necessarily have the right model of the
past okay so you know if you ask people
what was there before the FDA they'll
save
um and by the FDA itself emits the right
their pronouns are just FDA FDA okay
um so but basically why is that
important it's just something where
why is that either humorous or
interesting to you
they have a sort of in-group lingo where
when you're when you are kind of talking
about them the way that they talk about
themselves it is something that kind of
Peaks interest it's kind of like uh you
know in in La people say the 101 or the
you know right whereas in Northern
California they'll say 101 uh or people
from Nevada will say Nevada right it
just instantly marks you as like Insider
or Outsider okay in terms of how the
language works right and that's go ahead
that means just makes me sad because
that lingo is part of the mechanism
which creates The Silo the bubble of a
particular
thoughts and that ultimately deviates
from the truth because you're not open
to new ideas I think it's actually like
uh you know in glorious bastards there's
a scene in the bar do you want to talk
about no but it's good uh you can't uh
just to censor you this is like what
could be a podcast like Wikipedia you
can't cite
um Quentin Tarantino films no okay okay
okay sorry so basically like English
start going like one two three four five
and I believe it's like the Germans
start with like the thumb
something that you'd never know right
I'm even misremembering but I think
that's right okay so uh so she has got
the lingo all right right so if you guys
so coming back up basically
just talk about FD and then come back to
your question on on the the platform so
V what was v0 FDA C1 what's what does
the future look like V1 V1 was quote
patent medicines okay that's what some
people say but V1 was also Banting in
best okay Banting invest they won the
Nobel Prize in the early 1920s right why
um
they came with that gr for
um insulin supplementation to treat
diabetes and they came with a concept
they experimented on dogs they did
self-experimentation they had healthy
volunteers they experimented with the
formulation as well right because just
like you'd have like a web app and a
mobile app maybe a command line app you
could have you know drug that's
administered orally or via injection or
cream or you know there's different
formulations right dosage all that stuff
they could just like iterate on okay
with willing doctor willing patient
these uh you know these uh these folks
who were affected uh just spraying out
of bed the insulin supplementation was
working for them and within a couple of
years they had won the Nobel Prize and
Eli Lilly had scaled production for the
entire North American continent okay so
that was a time when Pharma moved at the
speed of software
when it was willing buyer willing seller
okay because the past is demonized as
something that our glorious regulatory
agency is protecting this from okay but
there's so many ways in which what's
really protecting you from is being
healthy okay as you know I mean there's
there's a zillion examples of this I
won't be able to recapitulate all of
them just in this podcast but if you
look at a post that I've got it's called
regulation disruption and the future
um Technologies of 2013 Coursera PDF
okay
um this lecture uh which I'll kind of
link it here so you can put in the show
notes if you want
um this goes through
like a dozen different examples of crazy
things the FDA did from
the kind of stuff that was dramatized in
Dallas Buyers Club where they were
preventing people from getting AIDS
drugs to you know their uh you know
various uh attacks on
um you know raw milk where they were
basically saying here's here's a quote
from FDA uh you know
um filing in 2010 uh there's no
generalized right to bodily in physical
health there's no right to consume or
feed children any particular food
there's no fundamental right to freedom
of contract
they basically feel like they own you
you're not allowed to make your own
decisions about your food there's no
generalized right to bodily and physical
health direct quote from their like
written kind of thing okay
the the general frame is usually that
FDA says it's protecting you from the
big bad company but really what it's
doing is checking it's preventing you
from opting out okay now with that said
and this is where I'm talking about V3
as critical as I am of FDA or the FED
for that matter I also actually
recognize that
um like the Ron Paul type thing of End
the Fed is actually not practical and
the FED will just be laughed at what
Bitcoin did was a much much more
difficult task of building something
better than the fed that's really
difficult to do because the fed and the
FDA they're like the Hub of the current
system people rely on them for lots of
different things okay and
um you're going to need a better version
of them and how would you actually build
something like that so with the fed and
with you know SEC and and the entire you
know the banks and whatnot crypto has a
pretty good set of answers for these
things and over time
all the countries that are not or all
the groups that are not the U.S
establishment or the CCP will find more
and more to their liking in the crypto
economy so that part I think is going
okay we can talk about that
what does that look like for biomedicine
well first what does exit the FDA look
like right so there actually are a bunch
of exits from the FDA already
um which is uh things like right to try
laws okay CLIA labs and laboratory
developed tests compounding pharmacies
off the little prescription by doctors
and countries that aren't fully
harmonized with FDA for example you you
know Kobe Kobe Bryant before he passed
away went and did uh stem cell
treatments in in Germany okay stem cells
have been pushed out you know I think in
part by the Bush Administration by other
things so
um those are different kinds of exits
right to try basically means you know at
the state level you can just try the
drug okay
um
clear labs and ldts that means that's a
path where you don't have to go through
FDA to get a new device approved you can
just run run it in a lab okay
compounding pharmacies these were under
attack I'm not sure actually where the
current you know statute is on this but
this is the idea that a pharmacist has
some discretion and how they you know
prepare mixtures of of drugs
um off little prescription by MDS so MDS
have enough like weight in the system
that they can kind of push back on FDA
an off-label prescription is the concept
that a drug that's approved for purpose
a can be prescribed for purpose B or C
or D without going through another you
know whole new drug approval process
um and then countries that aren't
harmonized right so those are like five
different kinds of exits from the FDA on
different directions
um so first those exits exist so for
those people who are like oh my God
we're all going to die or he's going to
poison us with you non-fda approved
things or whatever right like uh those
eggs exists you've probably actually use
tests or treatments from those you don't
even realize that you have right so it's
it hasn't killed you number one number
two is actually testing for safety you
know there's safety efficacy and like
comparative safety is uh it's actually
relatively easy to test for there's very
few drugs that are like
um there's tgn1412 that's a famous
example something there's actually
really dangerous to people right with an
early test so those do exist just
acknowledge they do exist but in general
testing for safety is actually not that
hard to do okay and if something is safe
then you should be able to try it
usually okay now what is that
decentralized FDA look like well
basically you take individual pieces of
it and you can often turn them into
vehicles and um
this is like 50 different startups let
me describe some of them first have you
got any drugs or something like that
recently I mean like prescribed drugs
prescription drugs and it was like no
that you clarify the answer is no yeah
uh prescribed drugs uh no okay so not
not along me antibiotics a long time ago
maybe but I don't know so you you know
how you have like a sort of like a
wadded Up chemistry textbook the package
insert that goes into these right yes
okay it's plotted Up chemistry text me I
love it that's what it is right that's
what a terrible user interface we don't
usually think of it that way why is your
interface so terrible that's a web of
Regulation that makes it so terrible and
uh you know there's actually guys who
try to innovate just on user interface
call like help I need help that was like
the name of the company a while back and
it was it was trying to explain the
stuff in plain language okay
just on user interface you can innovate
and why is that important well
um you know there's a company called uh
pillpack which innovated on quote the
user interface for drugs by giving
people a thing which had like a daily
blister pack so it's like here is here's
your prescription and you're supposed to
take all these pills on the first and
second and basically whether you had
taken them on a given day
was manifest by whether you had opened
it for that specific day okay this is
way better than other kinds of so-called
compliance methodologies like they're
guys who try to do like an iot pill
where when you swallow it it like gives
you measurements this was just a simple
Innovation user interface that boosted
compliance in the sense of compliance
with a drug regimen dramatically right
um and I think they got acquired or
would have you for a lot of money and
hopefully utilized effectively utilize
effective right oh sometimes sometimes
these companies that do incredible
Innovation it really makes you sad when
they get acquired that that leads to
their death not their scaling sure I
mean they did a lot of other good things
but this is one thing that they they did
well right so pillpack just shows what
you can get with improving on user
interface
why can't I mean we get reviews for
everything right one thing that you know
like people are sort of in my view
someone quote a context are like oh
biology thinks you should replace the
FDA with the help for drugs actually
there's something called phase four okay
of the FDA which is so-called
post-market surveillance do you know
that that's actually something where in
theory you can go and fill out a form on
the FDA website which basically says
I've had you know a bad experience with
a drug uh like theirs but for drugs yeah
so it's like it's called medwatch right
um and so you can do like voluntary
reporting and uh you can get like uh you
know like a PDF and and just like upload
it right is this a government uh like is
this.gov yes form 3500 B well I love it
it's HTML it's gonna be like from the
90s there it's gonna have an interface
yeah designed by somebody who's the
Cobalt slash Fortran programmer right
here we go here we go so basically the
3500b I hope to be proven wrong on that
by the way but so 3500b consumer
voluntary reporting when do I use this
form you were heard or had a bad side
effect use a drug which lets unsafe use
syrup the point is FDA already has a
terrible Yelp for drugs yeah it has a
terrible version of it yep what would
the good version look like the fact that
you've never I mean this fact you have
to fill out a PDF to go and submit a
report how do you submit a report at
Yelp or Uber or Airbnb or Amazon you tap
and their star ratings right so just
modernizing FDA 3500b and modernizing
phase four okay
is a huge thing is it can you comment on
that is there what incentive mechanism
forces the the modernization of that
kind of thing here's how it would work
for one pause to create an actual Yelp
yeah here's here's here's how that would
work right you go to uh you know the
pharmacy or you know wherever and you
hold up your phone and you scan the
barcode of the drug okay what does you
see instantly you see global reports
right by the way because your biology or
physiology that's Global right
information from Brazil or from Germany
or uh Japan on their physiological
reaction to your the same drug you're
taking is useful to you it's not like a
national boundaries thing so the whole
nation-state model of only collecting
information on by other Americans so
really you want a global kind of thing
just like you know Amazon book reviews
that's like that's a global thing other
things are aggregate at the global level
Okay so
what you want is to see every patient
report and every Doctor around the world
on this drug that might be really
important to your rare or semi-rare
condition just that alone would be a
valuable site who builds that site it's
uh it's it sounds like something created
by capitalism sounds like you could do
it by Capital it would have to be a
company yeah you can definitely do see
these well we don't have a world where a
company is allowed to be in charge of
that kind of thing well I don't know
Health one went down it just seems like
a lot of the
so it depends right basically this is
why you have to pick off individual
elements right right there's essentially
a combination of first recognizing that
um definitely is actually bad even be
able to say that that let me put it like
this it does a lot of bad things it is
something which you need to be able to
criticize you might be like well that's
obvious right well in 2010 for example
there's a book that came out if anybody
wants to understand FDA it's called
reputation and power yeah a lot of
people don't want to criticize FDA yeah
because they will retaliate against your
biotech or Pharma company yeah and that
retaliation can be initiated by a single
human being absolutely the best analogy
is you think about the TSA okay have you
flown recently okay do you make any
jokes about the TSA when you're in the
TSA line
uh usually you don't want to but they're
a little more flexible you know what can
I tell a story sure which is
it's similar to this I was uh in Vegas
at a club I don't go to clubs okay I got
kicked out for the I think the first
time in my life for making a joke with a
bouncer
and um because I had a camera with me
and you're not allowed to have a camera
and I and I'm I said okay cool like I'll
I'll take it out but I made a funny joke
that I don't care to retell but he was
just a little offended he was like
you're you're out I don't care who you
are I don't care who you're with
uh and he proceeded to list me the the
famous people he has kicked off but
there is I mean all of those the reason
I made the joke is I sensed that there
was a an entitlement to this particular
individual like uh where the authority
has gone through that's my authority
yeah right I almost wanted to poke at
that right and I think the poking The
Authority I quickly learned the lesson
well you I have now been rewarded with
the pride I feel for having poked
Authority but now I'm kicked out of the
club that would have resulted in a fun
night with friends and so on instead I'm
standing alone crying in Vegas which is
not a unique Vegas experience sure
actually a fundamental Vegas experience
but that I'm sure that basic human
nature happens in the FDA as well that's
exactly right so just like with the TSA
you know just to extend the analogy when
you're in line at the TSA right you
don't want to miss your flight that
could cost you hundreds of dollars and
so you comply with apps ludicrous
regulations like oh three ounce bottles
well you know you can take an unlimited
number of three ounce bottles and you
can combine them into a six ounce bottle
through the terrorist technology called
mixing yep okay Advanced right and uh
the thing about this is everybody in
line actually some fairly High you know
let's say call it influence or net worth
or whatever people fly right millions
and millions and millions of people are
subject to these absolutely moronic
regulations it's all but you know I
think uh a security theater is is
shire's term right A lot of people know
this term so millions of people are
subject to it it costs Untold billions
of dollars in terms of delays and why
not if you just walk up to right it um
it irradiates people and there's another
FDA thing by the way this is an FDA TSA
team up okay in 2010 the TSA body
scanners there were concerns expressed
but when it's a government to government
thing see a.com is treated with extreme
scrutiny by FDA but it's another.gov
well they're not trying to make a profit
so they kind of sway them on through
okay so these body scanners were
basically like applied to millions and
millions of people and this huge kind of
opt-in experiment it's almost I think
it's quite likely by the way that
if there was even a slightly increased
cancer risk that the net you know
morbidian mortality from those would
have outweighed the deaths from
terrorism or whatever that were
prevented right you can work out the
numbers but under you can just get the
math under reasonable assumptions it's
probably true
um if it had any increased Mobility
mortality I've not seen the recent
things but I've seen that concern
expressed you know 12 years ago
point being that despite the cost
despite how many people are exposed to
it despite how obviously patently
ludicrous it is you don't make any
trouble nor do people organize protests
or whatever about this because it's
something where
um people the security theater of the
whole thing is is part of it oh well if
we took them away there would be more
terrorism or something like that people
think right but it is fascinating to see
that the populace
puts up with it because it does one of
my favorite things is to listen to
Jordan Peterson who
um I think offline but I think also on
the podcast
you know he's somebody who resists
Authority in every way and even he
goes to TSA with a kind of suppressed
like all the instructions everything
down to when that whenever you have like
the yellow thing for your feet they they
force you to adjust it even slightly if
you're off just even I mean it's like uh
it's a cough it's a Kafka novel we're
living like TSA it makes me smile it
brings joy to my heart because I imagine
uh Franz Kafka and I just walking
through there because it's it's it
really is just deeply absurd but and
then the the whole motivation of the
mechanism becomes distorted by the
individuals involved the initial one was
to reduce the number of terrorist
attacks I suppose right now it's guns
and drugs basically it's like
essentially what they've done is they've
repealed the Fourth Amendment right
search and seizure they can do it
without probable cause everybody is
being searched everybody's a potential
terrorist so they've got probable cause
for everybody in theory and so what they
do they'll post on their website the
guns and drugs or whatever that they see
used in these scanners well of course if
you search everybody you're gonna you're
gonna find some criminals or whatever
but the cost of doing that is dramatic
moreover the fact that people have sure
been trained to have you know compliance
it's like the Soviet Union right where
um you know just grudgingly all right go
along with this extremely stupid thing
what's my point the point is this is a
really stupid regulation that has
existed in plain side of everybody for
20 years we're still taking off our
shoes
okay because some shoe bomb or whatever
number of years ago okay all of this
stuff is there as opposed to this
resilient other things you could
potentially do different paradigms for
airport security but now apply that to
FDA just like t a lot of what TSA does
is security theater arguably all of it a
lot of what FDA does is safety theater
the difference is there's far fewer
people who go through the aperture
they're the biotech and pharmaceos okay
so you don't have you don't have an
understanding of what it is to deal with
them number one number two is the
penalty is not a few hundred dollars of
missing your flight it is a few million
dollars or tens or hundreds of millions
of dollars for getting your company
subject to the equivalent of a
retaliatory wait time just like that
bouncer threw you out just like the TSA
officer if you make a joke or you know
they can just sit you down and make you
lose your flight right so too can the
FDA just silently
impede the approval of something and
choke you out financially because you
don't have enough Runway to get funded
right so just impose more wait time
guess what we want another six months
you know data is going to take another
six months your company doesn't have the
time you die right if you live you have
to raise a round at some dilute
evaluation and now the price gets jacked
up on the other side that's the one
thing that can give by the way in this
whole process
when when you push out timelines from
days to get a vaccine approved with or a
vaccine evaluator rather via challenge
trials to months or years the cost
during that time when you when you it
just increases non-linearly right
because you can't iterate on the product
it all the normal observations if it
takes you 10 years to launch a product
versus 10 days what's the difference in
terms of your speed of variation your
cost Etc right so this is part of what
it's not the only thing there's other
things there's AMA and CPT these are
things but
um this is one of the things that jacks
up prices in the US medical system okay
so now you have something where these
CEOs they're going through this aperture
they are uh they can't tell anybody
about it because if you read reputation
and power okay I'm gonna just quote this
because it's amazing amazing book right
it's written by a guy you know Daniel
Carpenter smart guy but he's an FDA
sympathizer he fundamentally thinks it's
like a good thing or what have you
nevertheless I respect Carpenter's
intellectual honesty because he quotes
the CEOs in the book you know verbatim
and you give some paragraphs and
essentially from their descriptions it's
like um think about like a Vietnam War
thing where you've got a pow and they're
like blinking through their eyes I'm
being tortured okay that is the style
when you read Carpenter's book you read
the quotes from these um from these CEOs
oh let me see if I can find it do you
recommend the book it's a good book yeah
or it's it's now a little bit outdated
okay
because it's like you know almost 10
years old still as a history of the FDA
it is well worth reading and by the
reason I say like the FDA is so
insanely important it's so much more
important than many other things that
people talk about but they don't talk
about it right I just want to read his
little blurb for it right this is 2010.
the U.S Food and Drug Administration is
the most powerful regulatory agency in
the world how did the FDA become so
influential and how does it wield its
extraordinary power reputation power
traces the history of FDA regulation
Pharmaceuticals uh revealing how the
agency's organizational reputation as
being the primary source of its power is
also one of its ultimate constraints
Carpenter describes how the FDA
cultivated a reputation for competence
and vigilance throughout the last
century and how this organizational
image has enabled agency to regulate
while resisting efforts to curb its own
authority first of all just that
description alone you're like wait a
second
he is describing this as an active
player it's not like
a DMV kind of thing which is passed
through it's it's talking about
cultivating a reputation it's power
resisting efforts to curb its own
authority right the thing is
now you're kind of Through the Looking
Glass you're like wait a second this is
kind of language I don't usually hear
for regulate Regulatory Agencies the
thing is the kind of person who becomes
the CEO of a giant company what do they
want to do they want to expand that
company
they want to make more profit
similarly the kind of person who comes
to run a regulatory agency or one of the
subunits or that person wants to expand
its Ambit
okay whether is that always obvious and
sorry to interrupt both for the CEO of
the company I know that
the philosophical idea of capitalism is
you want to make the thing more
profitable but
we're also human beings do you think
there's some fundamental aspect to which
we want to do a lot of good in the world
sure but the fiduciary duty will push
people to get the ambitious you know the
profit maximizing expansionist CEO is
selected for
right basically they believe crucially
they're not just this important they're
not just I mean some of them are Grand
Theft Auto make as much money as
possible but they believe in the mission
okay they've come to believe in the
mission and that is a person who's
selected Chomsky actually had this good
thing which is like I believe that you
believe what you believe but if you
didn't believe what you believe you
wouldn't be sitting here right so they
select for the kind of people that are
able to make a lot of money
and in that process uh those people are
able to have construct a narrative that
they're doing good even though what they
were selected for is the fact that they
can make a lot of money yeah and they
may actually be doing good but the thing
is with CEOs we have a zillion images in
television and media movies of the evil
Corporation and the greedy CEO we have
some concept of what CEO failure modes
are like okay now when have you ever
seen an evil regulator
have you can you name a fictional
portrayal of an evil regulator can you
name an evil see a lot a lot a lot a lot
but that's so interesting I'm trying I'm
searching for a deeper lesson here
you're right
you're right I mean there is co there is
of portrayals especially in sort of
authoritarian regimes or of the Soviet
Union where there's bureaucracy you know
Chernobyl you can kind of see within
that there's a direct the story of the
regulator but
um
yeah it's it's not as plentiful and it's
also doesn't have often doesn't have a
face to it it's just like bureaucracy is
this amorphous thing that results any
one individual you see they're just
obeying somebody else there's not a face
to it I'll be evil that's right the evil
is the entire machine that's right
that's what I call the school of fish
strategy by the way it's something where
you are an individual and you can be
signaled out but there's more
accountability for one person's bad
tweets than all the wars in the Middle
East right because it's a school of fish
yeah right so if the establishment is
wrong if the bureaucracy is wrong
they're all wrong at the same time who
could have known whereas if you deviate
then you are a deviation who can be
hammered down okay now the school fish
strategy is unfortunately very
successful because uh you know truth is
whatever if you just always ride with
the school of fish and turn when they
turn and so on uh unless there's a
bigger school of fish that comes in you
basically can never be proven wrong all
right and this is actually you know of
course someone who believes in truth and
believes in you know Innovation and so
on just physiologically can't ride with
the school of fish you just have to say
what is true or do what is true right
still you've described correctly you
know how it's faceless right so I will
give two examples of fictional
portrayals of evil regulators
one is actually the original
Ghostbusters
okay I did not expect that one but yes
yeah so the EPA is actually the villain
in that where they flip a switch that
lets out all the ghosts in the city and
essentially the guys coming in with a
head of steam as this evil regulator
that just totally arrogant doesn't
actually understand the private sector
or or the consequences of their actions
and they force the and crucially they
bring a cop with them with a gun so it
shows that a regulator is not simply you
know some piece of paper but it is the
police right and that cop with the gun
forces the Ghostbusters to like release
the game and the whole thing spreads
yeah the second example is Dallas Buyers
Club which is more recent and that
actually shows the FDA blocking a guy
who with a life-threatening illness uh
you know with AIDS from getting the
drugs to trees condition and from
getting into other people right
those are just two portrayals but in
general what you find is when you talk
about FDA with people
one thing I'll often hear from folks is
like why would they do that
right they have no mental model of this
they kind of think of it as
why would the why would this uh thing
which they think of as sort of the DMV
they don't think of the DMV as like this
active thing okay why would the FDA do
that well if it is because it's filled
with some ambitious people that want to
keep increasing the power of the agency
just like the CEO wants to increase the
profit of the company right I use that
word Ambit right why Ambit because these
folks are we know the term greedy right
these folks are power hungry
they want to have the maximum scope and
sometimes Regulatory Agencies collide
with each other right even though FDA is
under HHS sometimes it collides with HHS
and they've got regulations at conflict
um you know for example HHS says
everybody's supposed to be able to have
access to their own medical record FDA
didn't want people to have access to
their own personal genomes that
conflicts okay
um and both of those are kind of
anti-corporate statutes that were put
out but the hhs's thing being targeted
at the hospitals and FDA being targeted
with the personal genomic companies but
those conflicted right
um it's a little bit like cftc and SEC
have a door jam over who will regulate
cryptocurrency right sometimes
Regulators fight each other
but they fight each other there they
fight companies they are they're active
players this reputation in power book
The reason I mention it is
um I want to see if I can find this
quote so let me see if I can find this
quote reputation and power
organizational image and pharmaceutical
regulation at the FDA
so genentech's executive G Kirk grob
right Rob would describe regulatory
approval for his products as a
fundamental challenge facing his company
and he would depict Administration a
particularly Vivid metaphor I've told
the story hundreds of times to help
people understand the FDA when I was in
Brazil I worked on the Amazon River for
many months selling terramycin for
Pfizer I hadn't seen my family for eight
or nine months they're flying into Sao
Paulo and I was flying down from some
little village on the Amazon to Manus
and then to Sao Paulo I was young guy in
his 20s I couldn't wait to see the kids
one of them was a year old baby the
other was three I missed my wife
there's a quonset hut in front of just a
little dirt strip with a single engine
plane of fly me to menus I roll up and
there's a Brazilian Soldier there
the military Revolution happened
literally the week before so this
Soldier is standing there with his
machine gun and he said to me you can't
come in
I speak in pretty good Portuguese by the
time I said my God my plane my family I
gotta come in he said again you can't
come in I said I gotta come in and he
took his machine gun took the safety off
and pointed at me and said you can't
come in and I said oh now I got it I
can't go in there
and that's the way I always describe the
FDA the FDA is standing there with a
machine gun against a pharmaceutical
industry so you better be their friend
rather than their enemy they're the boss
if you're a pharmaceutical firm they own
you body and soul
okay that's the CEO of a successful
company Genentech he says he's told the
story hundreds of times
and Regulatory approval is a fundamental
challenge facing this company because
if you are regulated by FDA they are
your primary customer if they cut the
cord on you you have no other customers
and in fact until very recently with the
Advent of social media no one would even
tell your story it was assumed that you
were some sort of
you know corporate criminal that they
were protecting the public from that
you're going to put poison and milk you
know like the melamine scandal in China
I'm not saying those things don't exist
by the way they do exist that's why
people are like they can immediately sum
into mind all the examples of corporate
criminals right that's why I mentioned
those fictional stories those templates
even if Star Wars doesn't exist how many
times have you heard a Star Wars
metaphor or whatever for something right
Breaking Bad you know go ahead yeah but
the pharmaceutical companies are stuck
between rock and a hard place because
the reputation if they go to Twitter
they go to social media they have
horrible reputation so it's like they
don't yes but why is that because
reputation and power FDA beat down the
reputation of Pharma companies just like
EPA helped beat down the reputation of
oil companies and as it says over here
right in practice dealing with the fact
of FDA power meant a fundamental change
in corporate structure and culture at
Abbott and at Genentech Rob's most
Central transformation was in creating a
culture of acquiescence towards a
government agency as was done at other
drug companies in the late 20th century
Rob essentially fired officials at
Abbott who were insufficiently compliant
with the FDA what that means is de facto
nationalization of the industry
via regulation
just to hover on that that's a really
big deal
because if their primary customer is
this government agency
then it has nationalized it just
indirectly right this is partially
what's just happened with
um Microsoft Apple Google Amazon the
other Maga okay they have been yeah
that's funny well done
yeah I didn't even think about that as
well done it was right so it's a so the
you know like I have this trees like
Mega Republicans and mega Democrats
right okay
oh damn it so many things you've said
today will just get stuck in my head um
they changed the way you think catchy
something about a catchy phrasing of
ideas is makes me even more powerful uh
so yeah okay so that's happening in the
text it's happening in Tech so Facebook
is the outlier because Zuck still
controls a company but just like I mean
why had Tech had a good reputation for a
while because there wasn't a regulatory
agency whose justification was
regulating these corporate criminals
right once that is the case the
regulatory agency basically comes back
to Congress each year and if you look at
its budget approvals it's saying we find
this many guys we found this many
violations right they have an incentive
to exaggerate the threat in the same way
that a prosecutor or you know policeman
has a quota right like these are the
police you know one way I describe it
also is like
um you know like a step down
Transformers you have high voltage
electricity it's generated at the power
plant and it comes over the wires and
then there's step down Transformers that
turn it into a lower voltage that you
can just deal with out of your
appliances right similarly you have
something where the high voltage of like
the US military or the police and that
is transmuted down into a little letter
that comes in your mailbox saying pay
your 50 parking ticket
where it's a piece of paper so you don't
see the gun attached to it but if you
were to defy that it's like Grand Theft
Auto where you get one star two star
three stars four stars five stars and
eventually you know you have some some
serious stuff on your hands okay so once
you understand that you know every law
is backed by force like that Brazilian
guy with the machine gun that uh Rob
mentioned these guys are the regulatory
police okay now
see for a time what happened was
you had the captured industry because
all of the folks who were in
Pharmaceuticals were as Carpenter said
um
the culture of acquiescence towards the
FDA the FDA was their primary customer
so just like in a sense it's rational
you know Amazon talks about being
customer obsessed right what Rob did was
rational for that time right what geek
Rob did was uh saying our customers the
FDA that's our primary customer nobody
else matters they are satisfied first
every single trade-off that has to be
made is FDA right and uh you know really
that's why the two most important
departments at many pharmaceutical
companies argue all are Regulatory
Affairs and IP not r d right because one
is artificial scarcity of Regulation
which jacks up the price and the other
is artificial scarcity the patent which
allows people to maintain the high price
right so this entire thing is just like
you know college education these things
may at some point have been a good
concept but the price has just risen and
risen risen until it's at the limit
price and Beyond Okay so
what has changed what's changed is in
the 2010s late 2000s and 2010s and so on
with the Advent of social media with the
Advent of a bunch of millionaires
um like who are independent uh with the
Advent of
um Uber and Airbnb right with the Advent
of cryptocurrency with the domination of
trust and institutions it used to be
really taboo to even talk about the
fda's potentially bad in like you know
2010 2009 okay but now people have just
seen face plant after face plant by the
institutions and people are much more
open to the concept that they may
actually not have it all together and I
think it's a you know you you probably
see some tracking pull or something like
that but I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like a 20 or 30 point drop after the CDC
failed to control disease and the FDA
failed and the entire biomedical
regulatory establishment and scientific
establishment was saying masks don't
work before they do this was just a
train crash of all the things that
you're paying for that you you
supposedly think are good as I mentioned
one was response is to go Q Anon and
people say oh don't trust anything but
the better response is decentralizing
FDA Okay so
I will say one other thing which is I
mentioned um you know this concept of
improving the form 3500b where you like
scan go ahead uh yeah yeah right that
just makes me laugh that I could just
tell the form sucks by the fact that it
has that code name sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly right ux is broken at every
layer yeah so so they have a bad Yelp
for drugs could we make a better one we
could make a better one just modern ux
the key Insight here by the way which is
a non-obvious point and I've got a whole
talk on this actually uh that I should
probably release I actually did like
almost eight nine years ago it's called
regulation is information
product quality is a digital signal okay
what do I mean by that basically
when I talk about exit you know exit the
the fed that's the crypto economy right
what does exit the FDA look like well
one key Insight is that many of the big
scale tech companies can be thought of
as Cloud Regulators rather than land
Regulators what do I mean by that well
first what is regulation people do want
a regulated Marketplace they want a
quality ratings like on a one to five
star scale and B bands of Bad actors
like the zero star frauds and scammers
and so on and these are distinct right
somebody who's like a low quality but
well-intentioned person is different
than a smart and evil person those are
two different kinds of failure modes you
could have in the marketplace right why
is it rational for people to want a
regulated Marketplace especially for
health because they want to pay
essentially one entry cost
and then they don't have to evaluate
everything separately where they may not
have the technical information to do
that yes right you don't want to go to
Starbucks and put a dipstick into every
um
coffee to see if it's poisoned or
something like that you sort of want to
enter a Zone where you know things are
basically good and you pay that one
diligence cost on the Zone itself right
whether it's a digital or physical Zone
and then the regulator's taking care of
it and they've baked in the regulatory
cost into you know some subscription fee
of some kind right so the thing is the
model we've talked about is the land
regulator of a nation-state in a
territorially bounded thing but the
cloud regulator what's a cloud regulator
that is
Amazon star ratings that's uh Yelp that
is eBay that is Airbnb that is Uber and
Lyft and and so on and so forth It's
also actually Gmail and Google why
because you're doing spam filtering
and uh you are doing ranking of males
with priority inbox right uh with Google
itself they ban malware links right so
the Bad actors are out and they're
ranking them right how about Apple the
app store right they ban Bad actors and
they do star ratings when you start
actually applying this lens PayPal you
know they've got a reputation sir every
single web service that's at the scale
of like tens of millions or hundreds of
millions of people has had to build a
cloud regulator
and The crucial thing is it scales
across borders so you can use the data
from Mexico to help somebody in Moldova
or vice versa right because it's
fundamentally International right those
ratings that you have a network effect
and
um there's another aspect to it which is
these are better Regulators than the
land Regulators for example Uber is a
better regulator than the taxi
medallions why
every write is GPS tracked there's
ratings on both the driver and the
passenger side both parties you know
know that payment can be rendered in a
standard currency right if you have
below a certain star rating on either
side you get de-platformed and so on to
protect either a rider or driver and on
and on right
what does that do think about how much
better that is in taxi medallions rather
than a six-month or annual inspection
um you have reports from every single
writer okay before Uber it was the you
know the taxi drivers and taxi
Regulators were in a little Monopoly
locally okay because they were the
persistent actors in the ecosystem taxi
Riders had nothing in common didn't even
know each other some you know New York
some guy gets a taxi another guy they
had no way to communicate with each
other so the persistent actors in the
system of the regulators and the drivers
and they had this cozy kind of thing and
Medallion prices just kept going up and
this was a sort of collaboration on
artificial scarcity afterwards with Uber
and Lyft and other entrants you get
something interesting a different kind
of regulator driver Fusion if you assume
regulatory capture exists and lean into
it
Uber is the new regulator
and Uber drivers are the drivers Lyft is
the compete competing regulator and Lyft
drivers are the new drivers okay so you
have a regulator driver Fusion versus
another regulator driver Fusion you no
longer have a monopoly you have multiple
parties okay you have a competitive
market this is the concept of like
polycentric law right where you have
multiple different legal regimes in the
same jurisdiction overlapping that you
can choose between with a tap of a
button right all these Concepts from
like libertarian Theory like you know
polycentric law or taxi all these things
are becoming more possible now that the
internet has increased microeconomic
Leverage
and um because that exit is now possible
now
you may argue oh well Lyft and Uber
they're not profitable anymore and
there's two different criticisms of them
one is oh they're not profitable or oh
they're charging too much or and I think
part of this is because of certain kinds
of the the regulatory state is caught up
to try to make them uncompetitive for
example they don't allow people in some
states to identify themselves as
independent contractors even if they are
part-time okay
um there's various other kinds of rules
and regulations you know in Austin for a
while Uber was even banned what have you
right net net though like uber crab
gojack Lyft DD like ride sharing as a
concept is now out there and whatever
the next version is whether it's
self-driving like well it's like a very
hard-fought battle and the regulatory
State keeps trying to push things back
into the garage
this is a fundamentally better way of
just doing regulation of taxis similarly
Airbnb for hotels I mean it's basically
the same thing okay and
um now Airbnb could use competition I
think that it would be good to have you
know like competition for them and there
are other kinds of sites opening up but
the fundamental concept of the cloud
regulator now let's apply it here once
you realize regulation is information
the way you would set up a competitor to
FDA or SEC or FAA or something like that
is you just do better reviews
I can just start with that that's pure
information you're under free speech
that's like still you know the most
defended thing literally just publishing
reviews and not just reviews by any old
person it turns out that FDA typically
will use expert panels where there's
extra panels it's like professors from
Harvard or you know things like that
um so what that is is this concept of a
reputational bridge
what you want to do is you want to have
folks who are let's say biotech
entrepreneurs or they're you know uh
props like Sinclair or what have you you
do want to have the reviews of the crowd
okay but you also want to have
especially in medicine right there so
you want to have the reviews of Experts
of some kind so there's going to be
defectors from the current establishment
okay just like you know there are props
who defected from computer science
Academia to become Larry and Sergey and
whatever you know or they weren't
Prosper they were grad students right
um in the same way you'll have defectors
uh who have the credentials from the old
world but can build up the new just like
there's folks from Wall Street who have
come in cryptocurrency and helped
legitimate it right just like there's
folks who left
um salzburger to come to substack okay
um you know we have we have these folks
who by defecting they help and then
they're also supplemented by all this
new talent coming in right that
combination of things is how you build a
new system it's not completely by itself
nor is it trying to reform the old its
own Fusion okay so in this new system
who do you have you have like the most
entrepreneurial and Innovative MDS you
have the most entrepreneurial and
Innovative professors and you have the
founders of actual new products and
stuff and they're giving open source
reviews of these products and they're
also building a community
that will say look we want this new drug
or we want this new treatment or we want
this new device and we're willing to
crowdfund 10 000 units
so please give us the thing and we'll
write a very fair review of it and we'll
also all evaluate it as a community and
so on so you turn these people from just
passive patience into active
participants in their health that's a
community part and they've got the kind
of biomedical technical leadership there
now what is the kind of prototype of
something like this something like Vita
Dow is very interesting things like
molecule doubt are very interesting
it'll start with things like longevity
right and why is that because
the entire model of FDA this 20th
century model is
wait for somebody to have a disease and
then try to cure them okay versus you
know saying an ounce prevention is worth
a pound of cure right why are we not
actually tracking folks and getting a
constant dashboard on yourself so you
can see whether things are breaking and
then you you deal with it just like
you've got server uptime things you
don't wait necessarily for the site to
go down you start seeing Oh response
rates are spiking we need to add more
servers right you have some warning okay
even 10 years ago there's this article
called uh the measured man in the
Atlantic where the sky physicist Larry
smart Okay what he was doing is he was
essentially doing a bunch of
measurements on himself
and he was finding that uh there were
predictors of inflammation that were
spiking and he went to the doctor showed
the charts and the doctor was like I
can't do anything with this then that
turned out to be an early warning of
like a serious condition and he had to I
think go for like you know surgery or or
something and he was starting to think
well look the way that we're doing
medicine right now is it's not quite
um like pre-germ theory of disease
but it is
pre- continuous Diagnostics
okay continuous Diagnostics just to talk
about this for a second this is I I
mentioned one angle on which you go
after FDA which is like the the better
phase four right I've mentioned the
concept of better reviews in general
okay
I mentioned Vita Dao which is like a
community that is going after longevity
let's talk about continuous Diagnostics
so
basically
We Know Better what is going on in
Bangalore or Budapest in our own body
that's actually kind of insane to think
about the stuff that you know is all the
other side of the world ten thousand
miles away but you know a few
millimeters away you don't really know
what's going on right and that's
starting to change with all the
Quantified Self devices the hundreds of
millions of Apple watches and fitbits
and stuff right you're all starting to
see continuous glucose meters which is
very important they're starting to give
you readouts people are seeing wow this
is spiking my insulin or rather this is
like my my blood sugar and uh it might
be something you didn't predict it
varies for different people for some
people you know a banana isn't a big
deal for others it's actually quite bad
for the blood sugar what happens when
you extend that well about 10 years ago
a guy Mike Snyder
um professor at Stanford did something
called the integrone where he just threw
the kitchen sink of all the Diagnostics
he could at himself over the period of I
think a few weeks or a few months I've
got the exact duration he's able to do
things where you could see during that
period he like got a cold or something
and you could see in the expression day
the gene expression data that he was
getting sick before he felt sick he
could also see that something about that
like viral infection like uh
made him develop diabetes-like symptoms
if I'm remembering it accurately so you
could see oh wait a second these are
things that are
um that I can see in my readouts that I
would only have the vaguest
interpretation of as like a human being
right
and moreover he could take uh you know I
don't think he did this but if you took
treatments if you took drugs right
you could actually show what your steady
state was if you tracked over time show
what your disease state or six state was
and then this drug pushes you back into
non-disease State you can actually get a
quantitative readout of what you know
like steady state was right so that and
and that stay safe you know your
expression levels across all these genes
uh your small molecules basically
everything you can you could you can
measure
that's going to vary from person to
person right what's healthy and natural
for you may be a different Baseline than
for me for example people who are small
example people who are South Asian
um or have dark skin tend to have
vitamin D deficiency why because we need
a lot of sunlight so often inside you're
tapping on your screen so what do we do
take like actually significant vitamin D
infusions okay
that's like a small example of where
baselines differ between people okay so
continuous Diagnostics what could that
mean that could mean you know it's
things like the continuous glucose meter
it's Quantified Self it's like
continuous blood testing right so you
have a so-called mobile phlebotomist
this is something which uh phlebotomist
takes blood right mobile phlebotomy
would come to your office come to your
remote office this is a great business
for people I think you know you can
revisit this in in 2022 if people tried
this in the 2010s but I think it's worth
revisiting multiple botanist comes every
week or every month takes blood runs
every test right maybe that's you know a
few thousand dollars a year maybe
eventually gets to a few hundred dollars
a year
um and that's expensive in some ways but
boy that's better health insurance in
other ways yeah I mean it's amazing so
one there's a bunch of companies that do
this and I actually would love to learn
more about them what what one of them
it's a company called inside tracker
that sponsors this podcast they do that
but the reason I really appreciate them
they're the first ones that introduced
me to like how easy it is but it's also
depressing how little information
exactly as you beautifully put once
again how little information we have
about our own body
in a continuous sense yes and actually
also sadly even with inside tracker as I
collect that data how not integrated
that data is with everything else right
if I wanted to opt in I would like
I I can't just like Roofing off the top
of my head but I would like Google Maps
to know what's going on inside my body
maybe I can't Intuit at first why that
application is useful but there could be
an incredible like that's where the
entrepreneurial Spirit builds is like
what can I do with that data can I make
the trip more less stressful for you and
adjust the Google Maps thing kind of
thing that's right yeah so I mean one of
the things about this by the way is
because there are so many movies made
about darnos okay that's one of the
reasons why people have sort of been
scared off from doing Diagnostics uh to
some extent okay why because visas are
like oh this is another theranos and
like due diligence and everything
everyone's looking at it oh blood
testing one drop of blood huh hurts
recruiting essentially
um a lot of the media and stuff around
that basically it's pathologized the
thing that we want to have a lot more
entrance in right now you know one way
of thinking about it is
FDA is killed way more people than
theranos has all right way more just
take drug lag alone okay whenever you
have a drug that works and reduce
morbidity and mortality after it was
actually generally available but was
delayed for months or years
the integral under that curve is the
excess morbidian mortality attributable
to fda's drug lag
you could go back and do that study
across lots and lots of different drugs
and you'll probably find quite a lot
Alex tabarok and others have written on
this right Daniel Henninger is written
on this okay that's just like one
example I mean I gave the pandemic
example the fact that they held up the
euas for the tests and didn't do
challenge trials that's like you know
they're not that's like a million
American Dead that could have been
ordered to magnitude less if we had
gotten the vaccine out to the vulnerable
population sooner okay so you're talking
about something that has a total
Monopoly on global health and
um you know you can't know what it is
without that unless you have zones that
are FDA free but that have some form of
Regulation as I mentioned it's a V3 it's
not going back to zero regulation
everybody in a man for itself but it's a
more reputable regulator
just like um you know Uber is a better
regulator than the taxi medallions right
yeah I mean you're painting such an
incredible picture you're making me wish
you were FDA commissioner but I I there
are a bunch of people who tweeted
something like that after the you know
with the pandemic
um whatever go ahead yeah is that is
that possible like if you were just
given uh if you became FDA commission
could you could you push for those kinds
of changes or is that really something
that has to come from the outside the
short answer is no and the longer answer
meaning they'll that'd be funny if you
like the short answer is no the long
answer is yes
so to basically see a CEO of a company
it's well it's very difficult they can
hire and fire right so in theory they
can do surgery on the organism and like
you know Steve Jobs took over apple and
was able to hire and fire raise money do
this that he basically had root over
Apple like he was a system administrator
right he had he had full permissions
okay as FDA commissioner you do not have
full permissions over FDA let alone like
the whole structure around it right if
you're FDA commissioner you are not the
CEO of the agency okay lots of these
folks there uh have career tenure they
they can't be fired
um they can't even really be disciplined
there's something called the Douglas
factors you ever heard the Douglas
factors it's like the Miranda rights for
federal employees okay you have the
right treatment size so basically if
you've heard that federal employees
can't be fired the Douglas factors are
how that's actually operationalized
when you try to fire somebody
it's this whole process where they get
to appeal it and so on and so forth and
they're sitting in the office while
you're trying to fire them and they're
complaining to everybody around them
that this guy's trying to fire me he's
such a bad guy blah blah right and
everybody around even if you know they
may think that guy is doing a bad job
they're like wait a second he's trying
to fire you he might try to fire me too
and so anybody who tries to fire
somebody at FDA just gets a face full of
lead for their troubles what they
instead will do is sometimes they'll
just transfer somebody to the basement
or something so they don't have to deal
with them if they're truly bad okay but
the thing about this is there is only
one caveat Douglas Factor number eight
the notoriety of the offense or its
impact upon the reputation
of the agency there's that word again
reputation of reputation and power so
the one way you can truly screw up
within a regulatory bureaucracy is if
you sort of endanger the like annual
budget renewal think of it as like this
mini death star that's coming to dock
against the max Death Star for its like
annual refuel and it's talking about all
the corporate criminals that it's
prosecuted the quotas like the police
quotas the ticketing you know and
if they don't have a crisis they will
like invent one just again just like TSA
just like other agencies you're more
familiar with you can kind of map it
back look at the guns and drugs we've
seized and save an incentive for uh you
know creating these crises or
manufacturing them or exaggerating them
and if you endanger that refueling that
annual budget renewal or you know what
have you then the whole agency will
basically be like okay you're you're bad
and you can be disciplined or sometimes
you know with rare except you know you
can be booted but what that means is
that FDA commissioner is actually a
white elephant it's a ceremonial role
really right you know you know the term
white elephants like uh basically you
know the Maharaja gives you an out a
white elephant as a gift
seems great next day it's eating all of
your grass it's pooped on your lawn it
has like just put a foot on your car and
smash it but you can't give it away it's
a white elephant the Maharaja gave it to
you right that's what being like FDA
commissioner is it's the kind of thing
where
if
and a lot of people are drawn in Like
Moths To The Flame for these titles
of the establishment I want to be head
of this I want to be head of that right
and really what it is it's like
I don't know becoming head of Kazakhstan
in the mid-1980s in the Soviet Union the
Kazakhstan SSR right Soviet Socialist
Republic before the thing was going to
like crumble potentially right in many
ways it's becoming you know folks who
are just totally status obsessed getting
these positions but
um like a lot of the Merit all the folks
with Merit are kind of leaving the
government and going into you know
attack or crypto or what have you right
so even if these agencies were Hollow
before and somebody's becoming hollower
because they have less Talent there
right so a you can't hire and fire very
easily you can hire a little bit you
can't really fire
um
B A lot of the talent has left the
building but was there see we're
entering the decentralizing era and D
you know like be like Satoshi Satoshi
founded Bitcoin because he knew you
could not reform the FED there's
everybody is trying to go and reform
reform reform the reason they're trying
to reform is we haven't figured out the
mechanism to build something new and now
perhaps we have that so I've named a few
of them right I'll name one more
related to Deliverance Fitness is
actually the back door to a lot of
medicine okay why is that
um you go to any you know conference it
could be neurology it could be
cardiology you'll find somebody who's
giving a talk that says something along
the lines of Fitness is the ultimate
drug Maybe not today when people are
saying oh fat phobic whatever but not
too many years ago you'd see somebody
um people saying Fitness is the ultimate
drug if we could just prescribe Fitness
in a pill that would improve your
cardiovascular function your no large
functional depression by the way in that
case the the use of the word drug means
medicine so medicine yeah yeah sure uh
Fitness is the ultimate medicine yeah
yeah the ultimate medicine right so
if they could just prescribe the effects
of it it's just like boom just massive
effect right like you're fit enough you
do resistance training it helps with you
know preventive diabetes every kind of
thing in the world you see a significant
treatment effect
yet your Fitness is your own
responsibility you go to some gym 24
Hour Fitness what do they have they have
on the wall exhortations like your body
is your responsibility right am I right
yeah yeah and you know uh good but no
it's just it's hilarious yes yes it's
funny but it's true right yeah it's
funny because it's true and so your
Fitness your diet that's your
responsibility but when you go into a
doctor's office suddenly it becomes lie
back and think of England
okay suddenly you become passive
suddenly oh your doctor your doctor is
Doctor Google well your doctor must be a
[ __ ] you're you're going and trying to
take care of yourself you're Googling
symptoms oh how stupid you are I have a
medical degree and that doctor
see the thing is if you come in and you
you've self-diagnosed or you've done
some of your own research if you're
right there and if they've got an ego
about it they're undermined and if
you're wrong they're like you know haha
you know arrogant but either way they
have if they've got this kind of mindset
they have an incentive to resist the
patient taking care of themselves isn't
that the doctor's job right and they're
kind of taught to behave like this many
of them
so what that means then is that
intervention of that 15 or 30 minute
appointment with the doctor whatever
drug they prescribe better hit you like
Thor's hammer to put you back on the
straight and narrow because that's only
with you for like a few seconds you know
a few minutes or whatever the doctor's
in with you for a few minutes the drug
is only you know some drugs are very
powerful so they actually do work like
this okay but
your Fitness is your own responsibility
and that's a continuing forcing function
every day and again we get back to
decentralization right the
decentralization of responsibility from
somebody thinking themselves merely as a
patient to an active participant in
their own health who's doing their own
monitoring of their own health right and
logging all their stuff who's eating you
know properly and looking at the effect
of their diet on things like their you
know continuous glucose monitor is a V1
but other things right
um who is you know as fit as they can
possibly be like these are kind of
obvious things but why is this the back
door to medicine because
since FDA only regulates those things
that are meant to diagnose and treat a
disease
all the stuff that is meant to improve
an otherwise healthy person is
potentially out of their purview
supplements are one interesting aspect
that they were carved out uh in the in
the mid 90s and that's why the
supplement industry is Big because FDA
isn't it doesn't have as tired of rain
on that but all of the Fitbit uh CGM
continuous glucose user type stuff you
can crank out all kinds of things that
help people get fitter
that will also actually have just
general health value but you're not quit
marketing them to diagnose or treat you
know a disease see what I'm saying
you're marketing them for the purpose of
Fitness this is a market why because
psychologically people
they don't like paying to get back to
normal
but they will absolutely pay tons of
money to get better than normal they'll
pay for Fitness they'll pay for makeup
they'll pay for hair they'll pay for
this and that right so that's actually
the back door and you can do tons of
things there where obviously being
healthier
is also protective you can actually show
the studies on this so this way you
build out all the tooling
to get healthier and that actually helps
on this axis
a few other things which kind of a U.S
medical system while I'm Onyx you got me
on this topic I love this okay so this
is uh this is the most eloquent
exploration of the U.S medical system
and how to improve it how to fix it and
what the future looks like yeah so love
it so basically so part of it is
decentralizing control back to the
individual right now I've talked about
FDA length but let me talk about some
other other broken parts of the U.S
system right
um there's like AMA there's CBT there's
cpom there's this you know like all
these regulations which see normally
in capitalism you have a uh a buyer and
a seller right duh in medicine you have
third party regulation and fourth party
pricing and
um fifth party payment okay so
third-part regulation FDA is regulating
it fourth party pricing it is
um you know the the CPT codes right
fifth party payment it's the insurance
companies all right and just to discuss
these bits of the system
first
why are some people against capitalism
and medicine I actually understand why
they're against it because they are
visualizing themselves on a gurney when
they're being wheeled in and now
somebody at their moment of
vulnerability is charging this insane
price for their care and many people in
the US have had this horrible experience
where they're bankrupted or scared of
being bancrypted by medical bills
therefore the concept of adding more
capitalism venison scares them and they
think it's horrible and you're some like
awful greedy Tech bro kind of thing all
right
let me let me say I understand that
concern let me you know kind of let me
pull tease that apart a little bit right
basically the most capitalistic areas of
medicine are the most functional areas
of medicine so that's the places where
you can walk in and walk out okay
whether that's Dentistry Dermatology
plastic surgery even veterinary medicine
which is not human okay where you can
make a conscious decision say Okay I
want this care or I don't want this I
see a price list I can pay cash right if
I don't like it I go to another
dermatologist there's few Dermatological
emergencies that's why dermatologists
have a great quality of life okay by
contrast when you're being wheeled in on
a gurney you need it right now okay and
you're unconscious or what have you or
you're not in a capacity to deal with it
right
and so these are the two extremes it's
like ambulatory medicine you can walk
around and pick and like ambulance
medicine okay and what what that means
is the more ambulatory the medicine the
more legitimate capitalism is in that
situation people are okay with a
dermatologist basically turning you down
because you don't have enough money and
you go to another dermatologist because
you can comparison shop there it's not
usually an emergency right
whereas if you're coming in with an
ambulance
then people don't want to be turned down
and I understand why okay what this
suggests by the way is that you should
only have insurance for the edge cases
Insurance should only cover the
ambulance not the ambulatory and most
people are losing money on insurance
right because most people are paying
more in in premiums than they are
getting out it's just that this huge
flight of dollars through the air that
no one can make heads or tails out of oh
the other aspect that's obviously broken
you know is employer provided health
insurance just started after World War
II so you know auto insurance is in a
much more competitive market you don't
whip out your auto insurance card at the
gas station to pay for your gas right
you only whip it out when there's a
crash right that's what quote health
insurance should be and the Singapore
model is actually a pretty good one for
this where they have sort of a mandatory
HSA you have to like put some money in
that and um that pays for your health
care bills but then it's cash out of
that it's like a separate pocket it's
sort of four savings to pay for health
savings accounts health savings account
right the thing about this is once you
realize well first ambulatory medicine
is capitalistic medicine ambulance
medicine is socialist medicine okay you
want to shift people more towards
ambulatory guess what that's in their
interests as well now that brings us
back to the monitoring
right the continuous monitoring where
whether eventually it's Mike Snyder's
integrone the V1 is the Quantified Self
and the Apple watch and the you know
continuous glucose meters and a VN is
the Mike Schneider inch chrome there's a
site called Q dot bio which is doing
this also right eventually this stuff
will hopefully just be in a device that
just measures tons and tons of variables
on you right there's ways of measuring
some of these metabolites and you know
without breaking the skin
um you know so so it's like it's not you
don't have to keep breaking the skin
over and over there's various ways of
doing that so now you've got something
where you've got the monitoring you've
got the dashboards you've got the alerts
and just like this Larry smart guy that
I mentioned the measured man you might
be able to shift more and more things to
ambulatory and one of the things about
this also is the medical system is set
up in a bad way where the primary care
physician is the one who is like not the
top of their class but the guys who are
at the bottom of the pinball machine the
surgeons and the Radiology once your
stuff is already broken okay they're the
ones who are paid the most so a lot of
the skill collects at the post-break
stage right right where you actually
want Doogie Hauser MD is that the
Upstream stage okay so you want this
amazing amazing doctor there right how
could we get that I mentioned the app
that doesn't exist which is like a
better version of the 3500b right here's
another app that doesn't exist and this
is one that FDA is actively quashed why
can't you just take an image of a mole
or something like that you know with the
incredible cameras we have a huge amount
of Medical Imaging should be able to be
done at home and it goes to doctors
whether it's in the US or the
Philippines or India I mean
tele-radiology exists right why can you
not do that for Dermatology for
everything else you should be able to
literally just hold the thing up and
with a combination of both Ai and MDS
just diagnose that should exist right
um answer is
there's a combination of both American
doctors and the FDA that team up to
prevent this or slow this
um and you know one argument is oh the
AI is not better than a human 100 of the
time because it's not deployed yet
therefore it could make an error
therefore it's bad even if it's better
than 99 of doctors 90 of time another
argument is the software has to go
through design control okay now
basically once you understand how FDA
Works basically imagine the most
bureaucratic Frozen process for code
deployment at any company ever
and that is the most Nimble thing ever
relative to fda's design review so just
to review a talked about how FD was
blocking all this stuff B talked about
why ambulatory medicine is capitalist
medicine uh ambulance medicine and
socialist medicine C talked about how
with the diagnostic stuff we can shift
it over to ambulatory D talked about how
there's lots of things where you could
have a combination of doctor and Ai and
an app
um that you kind of quickly
self-diagnose some of this is happening
now the the some of the telemedical
telemedicine laws were relaxed during
covet where now people you know a doctor
from Wyoming can prescribe for somebody
in Minnesota like some of that stuff was
relaxed during covet okay there's other
broken things of alcoholism I'll just
name two more and then kind of move on
okay I mentioned like AMA and CPT okay
those are two regulatory bodies Amy
American Medical Association CPT current
procedural terminology okay basically uh
you know Marx's labor theory of value
where people are supposed to be paid on
their effort right
um
of course the issue with this is that
you'd be paying a physicist to try to
dunk and you know they'd be trying but
they wouldn't actually probably be able
to do it they'd be trying real hard
whereas you actually want to pay people
invasive results right cheaply attained
results are actually better than
expensively attained non-results perhaps
obvious okay nevertheless the way that
the U.S medical system has payouts it's
based on so-called rvu's relative value
units and this is something where
there's a government body
that sets these prices uh and it is in
theory only for Medicare but all the
private insurers key off of that and
um AMA uh basically publishes a list of
these so-called um the CPT codes which
is like the coding the biomedical coding
of this
and what each medical process is worth
and whatnot so it's like
I don't remember all the numbers but um
it's like a five digit code and it's
like okay I got a I got a test for
Cystic Fibrosis or a test for this or a
test for that God help you if you're
um medical billing is erroneous why the
insurance company will reject it
um because it doesn't pay for that this
is this giant process of trying to
encode
um you know every possible ailment and
condition into these CPT codes and that
you can literally get degrees in medical
billing just for this okay this enormous
inefficient industry okay like literally
medical billing is a whole field okay
yeah now what do you want to do when you
grow up I want to work in medical
billing in medical billing okay where
everybody's mad at you at all times yeah
part of what happens is when you give a
treatment when a doctor gives a
treatment to a patient
they can't like repo the treatment okay
like a car you sell a car you can Theory
repo the car so patient has a treatment
now
um what happens well the insurance
company uh
you know that that treatment is perhaps
provided look it's a lab test provided
by a company right the company bills the
patient
the company is supposed to charge a high
price why the insurance company wants it
to try to collect from the patient the
patient is scared oh my God they see
this huge price they um they sometimes
don't pay sometimes the insurance
company doesn't pay either and uh when
when a company is stiff by an insurance
company uh when a diagnostic I mean a
strip and step by insurance company it
has to jack up the price of everybody
else right everything boils down to the
fact that you don't have you know a
buyer and a seller the doctor doesn't
know the price of what is being sold uh
the buyer doesn't know the price of what
is being bought at the time it's being
bought uh neither party can really even
set a free price because there's this
rvu system that hovers above the buyer
feels they've already bought it because
they've bought Insurance the insurance
company doesn't want to pay for it
everybody is trying to like push the
price onto somebody else and you know
not actually show the sticker price of
anything and hide everything and so on
and so forth oh the other thing about it
is obviously lawsuits are over
everything everybody's mad out about
everything it's Health people are dying
okay so everything is just optimized for
Optics as opposed to results right
similarly actually many drugs are
optimized for minimizing side effects
and Optics rather than maximizing
effects which are totally different
criteria right you might have for
example a drug that only cures a
thousand people but doesn't have any
side effects versus one that cures a
million people but that has 10 really
serious side effects a year right and
the second one would probably not happen
because those side effects would be so
so big okay
how do you attack this I name a few
examples but I actually think the reform
is going to come in part from outside
the system in particular India is coming
online
okay why is that important well
you may have encountered an Indian
doctor or two okay maybe an Indian
programmer one or two all right and I do
think telemedicine
could explode right where you could have
an Indian doctor
um you know in India and there's a U.S
doctor
okay who's like a dispatcher
you see what I'm saying they've got all
these other Indian doctors behind them
they've got a telemedical app and you
are now doing something where uh these
relatively inexpensive Indian doctors
who are vetted by the American doctor or
the doctor in the jurisdiction is a
license become the back end doctors of
the world to some extent that's already
there with tele-radiology and other
kinds of things right but now that
you've got literally like a billion
Indians who've just come online okay you
have this huge pool of folks who have a
different attitude towards medicine for
example it's a lot more cash payment
over there for example India is big on
generic drugs for example during covet
it had something called uh has something
called a rogia sethu which is a national
telemedicine app okay the US wasn't able
to ship that in some ways India's
digital infrastructure again you'll have
to read a post called uh the internet
country by tigerfeathers.subsack.com and
you'll see that actually India's
national software infrastructure is
surprisingly good it's not as good as
China's in some ways but it's like
better than the US's which is like
healthier.gov and like non-existent it's
like kind of impressive good some of
India software is the fact that it
exists is good so you have all these new
doctors coming online India cranks out
generics right telemedicine is now more
legal in the US and you have uh cash
payment in India right and in a lot of
other places you don't have the whole
Insurance employer help thing and this
Market is growing
so you could have a sort of parallel
Market that starts evolving right which
is and people are only doing some
medical tourism I think that's another
exit from the FDA you have a parallel
Market that starts evolving that just
starts from fundamentally different
premises it's just cash
cash for everything right there's
downsides with cash for everything
there's a huge upside with cash for
everything cash for everything means you
give customer service from the doctor it
means the prices are actually visible
it ideally pushes you again towards more
ambulatory medicine rather than
ambulance medicine
it is monitoring constant monitoring
with the Quantified Self and whatnot as
opposed to just let your system fail and
then wheel you in right
um there's a reputational bridge because
now we've had a couple of generations
almost of Indian doctors in the US so
people know that there's you know
there's some very competent Indian
doctors they're a good chunk of AMA and
so that they can serve Lobby for this
and uh you have plenty of Indian
Engineers now I'm not saying India alone
is a Panacea but I do think that this is
a large enough parallel Market to start
doing interesting things and you could
see uh sort of medical tourism medical
migration to where it gives India an
opportunity to
basically
let go of the constraints of the FDA
yeah because and innovate aggressively
and and I mean it's just such a huge
opportunity to define the future of
medicine and make a [ __ ] ton of money
from a market that's desperate for it in
the United States because of all the
over the regulation that's right and I
think basically it's something where the
reason it needs to that would fix the
fdasr to interrupt yes we fixed FDA by
exiting the FDA right and then the FDA
would dry out and then it would
hopefully it might reform it might dry
out right and this is you know why
people are for example they're traveling
across borders you know they're getting
orders from Canadian pharmacies you know
a lot of this type of stuff we can start
to build Alternatives right I mean
India's generic industry is really
important because it just doesn't
enforce American IP there
so generic drugs are cheaper right and
it's quite confident it's been around
for a while so there's enough proof
points there where
um again I'm not seeing a Panacea it's
going to be something which will require
like American and Indian collaboration I
think there's gonna be a lot of other
countries and so on that are involved
but you can start to see another poll
getting set up which is a confident
enough civilization
that is willing to take another
regulatory path right and that is in
some ways doing better on National
software than the US's and it has enough
of a bridge to the US that it can be
that stimulation which you need which is
kind of something that outside poke